emmanuel macron qui reçoit aujourd'hui
juan guido le candidat autoproclamé au
venezuela en quête de soutiens
puisqu'après la colombie après la
belgique après la grande bretagne ou
encore la suisse celui qui s'était
autoproclamé président du venezuela il y
a un an poursuit sa tournée
internationale en quête de soutiens il a
été reçu cet après midi par emmanuel
macron à l'elysée il avait rencontré un
peu plus tôt dans la journée le ministre
des affaires étrangères jean yves le
drian
voyez les précisions sur place de notre
reporter nadège abderrazak depuis la
maison de l'amérique latine à paris
bonsoir nadège vous suivez pour nous
cette visite de wang wei d'eau à paris
qu'en est il exactement
mais à écouter magali juan guido est
arrivé il ya un peu moins d'une heure et
6 à la maison de l'amérique latine à
paris il est encore à l'intérieur où il
s'est entretenu avec deux cents 200
membres de la communauté vénézuélienne
pour faire le point sur la situation
politique actuelle du venezuela une
arrivée ici un du président auto
proclamé par intérim du venezuela un peu
chahuté mouvementée un puisque plusieurs
plusieurs manifestants l'ont attendu à
quelques dizaines de mètres de cette
maison de l'amérique latine pour des
manifestants pro maduro qui ont protesté
contre sa visite ici à paris et contre
ça sa tournée européenne qu'il dénonce
ce qu'il qualifie de honte je vous
propose de les écouter
pour nous c'est très important parce que
autant on dénonce macron autant ben
macron ne reconnaît pas nicolas maduro
donc ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'à un moment donné ben voilà là
la france choisit ses alliés de
circonstance quand les intérêts sont en
jeu
et puis on soutient un dictateur quand
quelqu'un qui ce topo cam président par
contre on va empêcher le peuple ici de
s'exprimer c'est pour ça qu'on a
toujours soutenu le gouvernement de
nicolas mathieu au delà de la possession
des états unis qui sont toujours en
train d'influencer pour les mettre des
coups d'état et aux ados et s'est
autoproclamé président même chez lui
aujourd'hui plus personne ne le
reconnaît et c'est une honte que la
france le reçoivent de cette manière là
il n'a aucune légitimité pour venir ici
et c'est pour ça qu'on manifeste et je
trouve que c'est inadmissible ce qu'ils
ont fait l'interdiction de complices
être devant ces gens là pour leur dire
merde non désolé de diane
mais je ne suis pas d'accord du tout
cette compte on défend les trouillon le
monde à l'envers
voilà une qui un peu plus tôt dans la
journée à roanne gouardo a été reçu à
l'elysée par à emmanuel macron est les
deux hommes ont évoqué le processus
électoral à mettre en place au venezuela
une rencontre dont s'est dit satisfait
wang wei d'eau un an après s'être
autoproclamé président par intérim du
venezuela juan bado et bien n'a pas
renversé nicolás maduro et il est en
train de perdre la seule institution qui
lui étaient acquises l'assemblée
nationale depuis le 5 janvier à luiz
apparat députés de l'opposition comme
mme royal gaillard wang wei d'or
revendique le perchoir du président de
l'assemblée nationale trois noyades ok
donc en tournée pour demander aux pays
européens est bien de réitérer leur
soutien juan bois idoki et et bien ne
devrait plus maintenant tarder à sortir
vous le voyez sur ces images croit une
gouaille d'eau qui quitte donc la maison
de l'amérique latine un sou et bien une
visite française
donc pour réclamer le retour la france
en de réitérer le soutien de d'emmanuel
macro vis-à-vis de roanne wider wang wei
d'eau qui va donc quitter l a france à
l'issue d'une tournée européenne riche
en événements il a été accueilli par
part par les dirigeants européens
mercredi à bruxelles un des dirigeants
européens qui n'ont pas abouti à des
mesures pourrait bien influencer le
processus politique au venezuela il a
aussi était à davos à davos juan
gouaille doha où il a et bien a demandé
aux dirigeants du monde entier de bien
de lui renouveler leur soutien nous n'y
arriverons pas seul c'est ce qu'il a
déclaré pendant ce forum économique de
davos donc voilà une année difficile qui
s'annonce mouvementée pour roye noyon
qui est applaudie ici à la maison de
l'amérique latine alors qu'il est en
train de quitter les lieux après et bien
une heure d'entretien avec une partie de
la communauté vénézuélienne ici à paris
merci beaucoup nadège pour toutes ces
précisions l'adage abderrazak en direct
de la maison de l'amérique latine à
paris